hey everybody welcome back tomorrow's in
this episode I'll be working on some
general detailing and Christmas
decorations and finishing up the station
area transfer track and a bit of the
surrounding area the most important
reason for they're kind of all over the
place idea of this episode is that I
left off the last episode at a point
where I was really not hoping to leave
it off ads which was a very unfinished
station where I was kind of hoping to
finish the station in the transfer tract
in the last episode but now I just kind
of have to clean up all of my stuff in
this episode get everything done so that
I have enough done before the last
episode so this was sort of a catching
up kind of thing where I went all over
the place and did all kinds of different
detailing and adding different scenery
foliage buildings details all over the
place to make sure that everything is
sort of clean and good to go for the
last episode so the first thing that I
wanted to go into is actually this
little extension into the station which
has sort of a triple kind of meaning
here for one it's it's an extension to
the station since I felt this station
was very small in terms of mass it just
kind of felt like a small roof a small
Tower and just sort of left it at that
and I think I could add a small
extension to it and actually give it a
bit more body but also this is a pretty
good cover for the train before it
enters the station this should actually
be where I have my block brakes located
so that when you are waiting you can
actually waits underneath a little cover
over here it doesn't mean that much but
it's also a cover for the bridge that
runs underneath it so there's another
function for it since I wanted to get
some sort of cover to fill up this
gaping hole that is pretty much made up
of the path going underneath the coaster
here by the way I made that tunnel just
because I felt it would be more
interesting there's actually enough
clearance underneath the track to go
underneath it without having to dig into
the ground
a little bit further away from the
station I just felt that this would be
much more interesting in terms of
composition since we have the path going
underneath the coaster then we have the
coaster and then above that again we
have the station so there's an
interesting layer
in there I felt and that's just
something that I wanted to try over here
so it might not be the most logical
thing it's something that I felt like
missing around a little bit with so
that's pretty much that addition it's
nothing too complicated and here you can
really see that I was able to save some
time by taking the pieces that I made
earlier on and by having them really
become these well pieces that you can
reuse in different kinds of ways they're
very modular in that sense I can at
least reuse them and save some time in
these episodes that doesn't go however
for this spire here I definitely wanted
to get another spire because right now I
sort of have the one spire on the left
side of the station but that aside there
isn't really any high sort of mark for
the building and now when I added that
large sort of horizontal part with the
bridge cover it felt like it was a bit
too boring and especially you know
houses like this or sometimes quite
overused and a bit sugar-coated so I
wanted to try and make a new tower bit
smaller and a bit simpler and actually
based off of the idea of the tower that
I had earlier on just with a different
top and with a different bottom so here
I'm decorating the top with all of these
different pieces which if you give them
all the same or generally the same
looking colors you can mix all of these
different wooden Gingerbread and
Christmas decoration pieces in so many
amazing ways and definitely in this
sense the Christmas update has been
really what I've been looking for in
extremely small details that you can use
to just add that little bit of boom to
any kind of spire or tower that you're
looking for so that's this was just more
of a experimentation with that now here
I just sort of went off topic for
minutes and decided to work on the cue
for a little bit which is gonna do like
two things that cues usually do it has
one part or two parts really we're just
sort of snakes through the landscape
where I just want to have trees rocks
any kind of scenery around it to make it
more interesting and then it has a very
small part where it snakes around
I didn't end up making that part larger
because then it felt like the building
would become a little bit yeah little
bit solid bulky and not as handy as I
wanted to do it in this very small space
so it's gonna be very small sort of
ruining a cover for that little part
where the cue snakes but I think that'll
provide some interesting little scenes
over here with the pond the coaster and
then the future roof over that small
snaking part of the cue
it all sounds a little bit weird but
basically what I was imagining at this
point is that from the cue underneath
that building there is a great very
small sight line onto the coaster where
you see the coaster sort of loom up in
the distance over that little pond but
from the other side from the coaster
side
I think the Hutt's will also look quite
nice with having the roof over the queue
on the side of the lake and just make it
a bit more interesting than just a
simple lake with nothing next to it now
back to the building of the station
itself I just sort of left the extra
spire which I built over here alone for
a little bit so I wanted to get back to
that and actually start decorating more
of it and so the first thing that I
wanted to get into is actually make the
the posts that hold up the roof I just
took the same Bela Straits to keep that
all the same within the building but I
definitely wanted to switch up the kinds
of posts that I'm using especially since
I needed to look for a new size here so
we're just combining a bunch of
different wooden and maybe not so wooden
elements I made these decorative wooden
posts eventually I did figure I didn't
want to have them on the sides of the
roof like this since that just looks
very derpy so I figured I would move
them inside a little bit more have the
roof stick out a bit and let's actually
look which I'm pretty glad with at this
point
so that's that sign of the tower and
then it still kind of felt alone so I
decided to add a very small extension to
it it's not gonna really be much to it
this was actually inspired by some of
the Russian concept drawings that I
found on the Internet there or many of
these actually found these pop up on our
architecture recently and I was like hey
I've seen those so many times but
they're really beautiful concept arts
and a couple of them have these kinds of
similar pavilions so I pretty much took
a pavilion and stuck it on top of this
roof here and that's the very basic
premise really so with that little
extension out of the way oh I still have
to do is add a small roof to the
extension as well I'm not sure how
anybody could actually reach this part
since there's not really any staircase
or anything this is all very decorative
but not actually having any function
outside of that I was thinking of making
this a clock tower but then the bell in
the clock tower turned out to be way too
large I might try a Christmas bell for
that but for the time being this is just
a useless small extension to the
building that's mostly just a way to
balance out the mass of the building
I felt since it was really leaning
toward the left with the large tower
here and I really wanted to sort of
build a counterweight do that pretty
overwhelming tower that's why I wanted
to put this small spire here now with
that done the station building is almost
done and you can probably see now that
there aren't many unfinished bits maybe
some lamps here and there some planters
to dress it up a bit and of course
Christmas lights but that aside the the
station is pretty much done at this
point so I wanted to get into some of
the decorations here around the station
to kind of get a feel for what the
entire area around it would look so I
went into a couple of fences over here
bit of rock work bit of foliage keep
keeping it very simple you know I don't
add any flowers or anything that you
would need summer for but I still wanted
to make it somewhat lights so with a
little bit of variation between the
types of rocks and the types of foliage
I feel like there is still a wintery
enough feel to it while at the same time
keeping it a bit more colorful
it's one of the ways in which I'm trying
to get around the fact that you know
there are only two trees available in
the winter theme and they both look more
or less identical and that's really a
big challenge when it comes to the
foliage is how do you actually make a
foliage palette which is interesting to
look at which is flexible and has a lot
of variety in it with just two trees and
I think because of that I'm actually
focusing a lot more on the ground
shrubbery and the rock work to balance
out it's the very simple color palette
of the trees that I have here which is
also kind of why I started using this
brown inch rock because even though it's
it's very lights and it's maybe a bit
too brownish it does look a bit like the
rocks that you would see around like
Northern Europe and it's just a way to
get a bit more color in especially the
color blue or generally whites for me is
a bit for with a winter theme since it
very easily becomes overwhelming and
there's no real contrast to speak of so
I really wanted to get as much color in
with the rock work and with the ground
show every as I can to well to get rid
of that overwhelming presence of whites
you can kind of see it in the ground
textures as well
I painted a bit of soil around the rocks
and underneath the coast of track so you
kind of have the idea of the snow being
degraded in some places or less thick
where it doesn't really have as much
place to settle
so hopefully metal or end up blending
together very nicely
speaking of blending again this this
little bush that I just placed one here
is still one of my favorite bushes it's
like the desert looking Ross and I'm
pretty sure it's also supposed to be
desert across but what n7 one said about
the beach cross in rollercoaster and
three that it's an amazing way of
blending foliage together because it
just adds those couple little models of
foliage in-between otherwise empty areas
and it's that kind of thing which I
think this bush does really well so
usually wherever I have Rock work or
wherever I sort of have the border
between the trees and an open area I
love to use these kinds of dry bushes
blend everything together so you can
probably see this a lot more in the snow
here because I decided to still use
these bushes even though there's snow of
course and the snow just makes them pop
out a little bit more and be a bit more
obvious than they would be in the cross
but it's still something that I quite
like you
now finally I mall not really finally
but I wanted to finally I suppose
because it's been taking a while to get
to this I wanted to get to the
decorations on the station and actually
give it a Christmas feel to it so far I
didn't really have any Christmas
decorations on top of it none of the
typical lights or plants and I
desperately wanted to change that so one
of the first things that I go into is
actually put a bunch of planters around
these things and wall a tree I suppose a
couple of trees over here as well but um
after doing all of these trees I'm
coming back again to the station and
doing a lot of lights and the lighting
turned out to be a bit challenging but
definitely something that was a lot of
fun to do as well
and something that I don't know I think
it adds to the station at night I'm not
so sure about day though because they do
kind of pop outs at day and kind of just
look like an eyesore because you know
you don't need them at day anyway but
still it's something which has to add to
the Christmas feeling so at that point I
was just very quickly testing it to see
how it would go because the the second
thing that I sort of wanted to get into
here a spotlights so far I just have
like some simple lanterns and some
simple hanging lights in those hedges
but I didn't have anything to light up
the entire building itself so I wanted
to build a spotlight post I just didn't
have any other place to put a spotlight
spotlight in a good way that I could
light up the building because the rest
of this entire area is just pulse so I
ended up putting this post over here and
see how that could work and I wasn't
really too sure about the colors right
away I always just kind of like to think
about what I'm gonna do with this kind
of thing and in the end I just sort of
settled with a very warm orange
yellowish color to it
and that should hopefully light up the
building quite nicely then it's actually
all visible and also complements the
future lining strips which I'll have in
a very traditional Christmas sense and
also I one is a bit some post in here to
light up the coaster itself I tried it
with with spotlights on the ground at
first but that didn't really end up
working all that well it didn't really
line up the track as much as I was
hoping for and especially these posts
were able to get a bit more close to
them I'll see if I can replace these
lanterns which I have on the side of
these posts with actual lights hanging
on the side of the spotlight post but
that's something that I might mess
around with in the future but for now
these are just important to line up the
coaster because this is such an
important scene this is really where
you're walking into the park and where
you're seeing everything so I want to
set the best impression over here and
obviously no I didn't really talk about
this yet but um I'm a very firm believer
that courses are built to be looked at
as well which is why I have like the
entire first drop and the looping pretty
much on the full view from the path you
can't really get any closer to it and I
really wanted to make the most use out
of that source of put an extra spotlight
only and now I actually went into the
Christmas strips which should definitely
add a much more Christmassy feel to the
entire build and the there's no real
strategy to this at all I suppose there
was a little bit of research I always do
research - like many of the things I do
or at least I generally know stuff about
them but this was completely new
territory for me actually which sounds
weird and stupid but I've never actually
done like traditional Christmas lights
as you would see that very often I think
American homes do them I'm actually
seeing you know some of these shows on
YouTube which are so amazing where they
actually time the lights and somebody
did this in planet coaster as well I
forgot the name but I'll link it down in
the description there was this awesome
video of somebody doing a a timed
lighting like show on a house in
Christmas style using triggers and it
had over 9,000 triggers I've always been
trying to make a joke here it actually
did and it's absolutely amazing
I'm not doing that kind of thing here
but I wanted to light up the building so
that we actually have a bit of a
Christmas feel to it so that's what I'm
doing here and also some of those
spotlights are kind of slightly
strategically placed because these
lights these light strips don't actually
have like any ambient lights to them but
just a strip of lights but they don't
actually light up their surrounding
areas so I wanted to also focus some
spotlights in the area around those
pieces and actually kind of make it look
as if they are glowing and as if they
are sort of glowing around the area of
the roof which they're placed on and in
some places I just had to play
spotlights on the roof itself just to
light up certain areas of the building
and not leave them in the dark so that
was a bit of interesting work but
generally I'm very happy with how these
lights turn out I think they turn out
fine atmospheric add a lot to the
building especially of night and you
know this is probably the first case
where I think recording at nights for
the final video is gonna be an absolute
focus for me as well like the night time
is something that I haven't gone into as
much so far I've definitely worked with
the lighting before I love the lighting
in the game I think it's one of the
strongest points actually and I've
definitely played around with it in the
past but I just haven't done anything
that's very focused on the the way that
it looks at nights and that is
definitely the case with this coaster so
that's that's a change which is quite
interesting so here still just kind of
like doing all of the different
decorations
they are pretty much all over the place
it's just going to you know any part of
the station just look at it and just
kind of feel you know what could I add
over here is that maybe you'll enter
missing could I add some planters over
here it's just looking around adding
stuff here and there which is very much
just it's just a very primal and error
kind of process with no real thoughts
behind it otherwise and the very final
thing that I wanted to get into before I
get into the next video and I try to do
this as quickly as possible which is why
it might seem like a bit of a cheap
building at this point but finally I
wanted to get into the transfer track
filling or well not really transfer
track building those
which building next to the transfer
track I have a lot of questions about
these things and well I don't want to go
into detail with this the reason that I
am making these is really because it's a
realism issue coaches like these most
coasters in any case usually have a
transfer track and an area like this
where they can store their second train
so in any case usually whenever there is
a coaster with two trains you're going
to want to be able to get one of these
trains off the track and that's why I
have these transfer tracks where you can
drag it onto a separate piece of track
which usually goes into a storage or
maintenance or just a piece of track
where it can be stationed in that and
these are just for you know various
purposes if you don't want to run with
two trains for a time of day or for an
entire day you can store the other train
in there if it needs to be maintained or
taken off that's a way to do it and
that's just I I personally want to add
these things because it's it sort of
gets rid of any necessary potential
suspense of disbelief that you would
need so basically if you're riding this
coaster in planet coaster it could feel
like it's an actual real coaster because
the track looks like a BM the bolts are
there the speed is good the layout is
good you know I don't know exactly say
that but you know what I mean like all
the realistic components are there and
for me having that transfer track at the
end of the track but also seeing it
around the station just adds to the
realism of it and you know kind of makes
it seem like a dream that's closer to
reality than actually being a dream in
the end it's still a game of course it's
not real but it just makes it a bit more
interesting for me and I I feel like
there are quite a few people who agree
with that because I actually remember in
the roller coaster in three days
creating transfer tracks was an art of
its own and something that still right
now even in planning a coaster a lot of
people are very invested in
and it's definitely one of the very
interesting technical components of a
rollercoaster so that's pretty much this
in terms of building though it's very
simple so I wanted to just create a
simple check where the Train could be
and there is pretty much it's and that's
also it for this episode so thank you
guys so much for watching and I hope to
see you guys in the next episode in
which I'll be working on my small huts
and some general surrounding scenery see
you later guys